hi I'm Matt Welch with my co-author  Nicholas B of the Declaration of  Independence we're here on ask a  libertarian day next question comes via  twitter from vinegar Tom okay why is it  that I agree with your politics but find  a lot of you to be smarmy prigs this is  obviously intended for Nick I am not  exactly sure what smarmy prigs are  there's no question that a lot of  libertarians have a kind of social  deficit and I suspect that it may be the  leaching of plastic toxins from the  pocket protectors that they have or  slide rule splinters going into the  blood stream directly you know what the  fact of the matter is libertarians like  you know like lifesavers come in all  kinds of flavors some are jerks some are  not the important thing about  libertarians as they believe in a system  where you can ignore them so you can  always walk away and you can always walk  away steamed or happy but you can always  walk away so come on aboard